[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
happy hump day
[Music]
40
billion dollars and the republicans do
not think democracy all around the world
is worth very building it's just not
worth the money it's not worth the money
to save democracy all around the world
it's much more important to keep a
murderous dictator in power
i mean that that's way more important
than any amount of money to them is to
make sure
to make sure that vladimir putin
is in power
really
i mean you know it's tough to make this
[ __ ] up anymore
and they continue to um
beat this drum but they absolutely love
vladimir putin and anything any anything
that threatens vladimir putin and
vladimir putin's reign and vladimir
putin's scourge on democracy
they [ __ ] hate it
tulsi gabbard
tulsi gabbard doesn't even know tulsi
gabbard is a [ __ ] russian asset at
this point fox news
blasting russian propaganda day after
day minute after minute hour after hour
after hour
the house of representatives voted
to advance 40 billion dollars to protect
ukraine
from a murderous dictator in russia
whoosh
and the republicans are very pissed off
about this very very very pissed off
this morning
about vladimir putin having 40 billion
dollars dumped on his head
to defeat him
in ukraine apparently
vladim the ukrainians have drove out the
russians in four different
cities in ukraine
so that they're advancing
and defeating russia
and their occupation of a sovereign
nation a democracy wanting to take over
that democracy
hill
boy
what a morning what a morning we got a
lot of news to get to too
don't worry there's plenty of stuff to
talk about today
john eastman
which i'm sure will be a huge part of
our subject matter today john eastman
and his emails oh emails emails emails
her emails can you imagine if hillary
clinton
sent an email to her daughter about a
wedding oh my god we can't have that
person in charge
hunter biden's laptop
and here we have john eastman
sending sending
sending digital records
of a coup
like emailing hey here's how here's how
you here's how you overthrow the
constitution of the united states
let me commit treason in this email
but oh my god hillary clinton had one
email one email that had that had a
sentence in it that was marked that may
have been or may not have been marked
classified
oh the horror
we need to find hunter biden's laptop
where is it
is it in rudy giuliani's pants where
he's tucking his shirt in
this is why they say this stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] today they're saying
they're saying about [ __ ] baby
formula this [ __ ] nonsense about baby
formula that somehow joe biden
because we gave 40 billion dollars to
ukraine
there's no baby formula and joe biden
and the democrats don't want children to
eat get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
the only political party
that has made it their [ __ ] mission
to tear down snap
and wick food assistance in this country
is the fascist republicans
continue every single year in the state
and the federal level
to [ __ ] absolutely bang up with a
hammer and smash food assistance for
children and they're gonna they're gonna
[ __ ]
they're gonna spread the lie that
democrats don't want [ __ ] baby
formula
because the the [ __ ] lie is is that
the goddamn plant that makes the
formula has a recall
it killed
it killed children so they had to recall
it
the formula
and they're still trying to catch back
up
with the supply because it was all
[ __ ] recalled because it was killing
children you would think that people who
gave a sh a solid [ __ ] about a clump of
cells
a couple days old and a woman's body
would give a [ __ ] about children dying
from poisonous formula and want to
recall it and correct it even if it
means that there is a shortage and that
we have to work through that
nope [ __ ] that [ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ]
we just want to blame it on joe biden
just like this morning we have we have
the cpi
the consumer price index
and inflation oh it's all joe biden's
fault
it's all joe biden's fault the housing
crisis
the amount
listen the reason why houses are so
[ __ ] expensive is because there was a
dumb [ __ ] who was the president who put
tariffs on building materials
lumber didn't start going up when joe
biden became president folks
you go back and look up when lumber
started it's when that dumb [ __ ]
started to think that terrace was a good
idea
that china is gonna pay for tariffs no
the american people pay for tariffs and
we're paying for it still
it's really bone-headed [ __ ]
bone-headed type stuff
i want to welcome everyone this morning
do you like the hump day outrage
let's get with it here
kelly is here kathy here kimberly midas
robin david debbie from salt lake
christina skip is here
we've we've got nancy's here rhonda's
here
uh minus margie lisa from facebook is
here ty is here
good morning cindy from facebook mj is
here lisa from facebook is here
anita cindy
uh holy moly we just have so many new
new listeners um for all you new
listeners out there if you want to know
how and where and how to find us
you go to youtube twitter twitch we air
this show live
we live stream every single weekday
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch just go to the
tubes of you and search the tony
michaels podcast you will find our
channel there subscribe to our youtube
channel
also we simulcast to all you people out
there on the books of face we simulcast
to the midas touch facebook page where
proud partner might as touch
thank you my zealous brothers
for helping us get the outrage out there
we stay pissed here on the tony michaels
podcast as you know
and if you don't know new listeners out
there
we stay pissed we stay fired up every
single weekday monday through friday and
we also air on the weekends
what happens on thursday tomorrow we
will release a
poll it's called the bonehead of the
week poll
sometime in the evening where you the
audience you the listeners have the
chance to vote for who is the bonehead
of the week and boy we have some good
contenders already
don't we
susan collins scared of chalk john
eastman
and his coo emails
i i just to name a few i mean i'm sure
by tomorrow there'll be a whole another
slate of boneheads
they never disappoint
so we put out a poll on twitter and now
on youtube so go follow us on twitter
don't miss that poll at tonymichaelspod
follow us over there on twitter and you
will find the bonehead of the week poll
tomorrow
then on friday we go through the
bonehead of the week
and then on sundays we clip out the
bonehead of the week where you decide we
break down the bone head of the week for
you the viewers and we re-air the bone
head of the week on sunday we also
put it on all the podcast directories so
we are now seven days a week folks you
can download us on apple spotify google
on all your favorite directories
don't forget we are seven days a week
we go live monday through friday for two
hours saturday we released a best of the
week of the tony michaels podcast for
you to enjoy
the best clips of the week
and then on sunday we air the bonehead
of the week there's a lot of the week
because it's a week oh my god
and in our world it's like six years
packed into a week almost
because of these [ __ ] fascist
boneheads
it just is never ending never ending
the america first um
was trending this morning with john
eastman
america first and john eastman were
trending
because
john eastman was trying to have a
fascist takeover of the country piss on
the constitution [ __ ] on it throw it
away
toss it out toss it to the side
and the america first there's a there's
a division in america first you guys
know we we dog on nick fuentes here
um he is he is the messaging god
of the republican party and i have some
video that i want to show gabe because i
know gabe is a big big huge fan
our co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez is a big huge fan of nick
fuentes i mean
he loves this guy
but i have some great video that you
guys are definitely going to enjoy
uh today of nick fuentes
and we also have some news to break down
there was a journalist killed
it appears to be the reports are by
israeli soldiers
al-jazeer
journalist
there is a very graphic video
out there we may show it if we get to it
we may show it so i'll warn you in this
video it's not ever
actually being shot but um it is
her on the ground after she's been shot
and um it appears that the israeli
sniper the israeli gunman are still
shooting
at her press sidekick there um and the
video clearly shows now it doesn't show
who is shooting
but the reports are that israelis were
the ones who
shot at her she had a press flak jacket
on and clearly marked press
um it would be tough to confuse the
person to not be breast especially her
confidant that was with her
in the video um
some some folks go over and get the
confidant the press confident i'm not
sure who that person is um out of the
situation
and trying trying to recover
um the journalists that was killed now
this is this is very disturbing and the
reason why
it is disturbing
do you hear that journalists are being
murdered it doesn't matter by who or
where or when or how
um this is this is a very very very deep
cut to democracy and freedom and rights
all around the world
especially when someone who is clearly
marked press
is shot and killed and it seems to be
somewhat intentional because they kept
firing as people were trying to
to try to render her aid
and were firing at her press confidant
there
um while she was on the ground
that's what the video shows
you go watch the video on twitter again
we might play it today it's kind of
graphic but you know we do not look away
here at the tony michaels podcast we
just do not
we look at all the facts
and we stay [ __ ] pissed about them
so
we may look at that video um it is uh
oh
it is a very very very very very
very disturbing
uh
video so we may look at that we may look
at that we also have some news about
marco rubio josh hawley uh true social
has some news
with elon musk and twitter all tied in
into a bow
um boomers has been trending also the
gop tax scam is trending
uh let's see what else do we have
trending today oh zillow did you guys
see the video of the house that gets
taken out to see we'll watch that video
today maybe
we got a lot of video to get to you know
we like the video here
and we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
and since we have a long way to go and
we got a lot of [ __ ] to round up let's
just go ahead and start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast where we and we're
reached the shitless roundup where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of the day
um someone is noticing over on facebook
that
that our viewership is down that they're
not receiving the notification over
there
maybe
maybe facebook you know a zuckerberg is
a is a putin puppet too oh he [ __ ]
loves putin zuckerberg loves putin
facebook loves putin they love the
russians
over there on facebook maybe my title
really pissed him off this morning
the title of the show is 40 billion to
defeat putin
they're probably just absolutely pissed
absolutely best how dare you tony
how dare you choose a title that would
throw cut so deep to our god putin i
mean i'm i'm dead serious i i believe
that so if you're over on facebook go
ahead and share the
[Laughter]
share the broadcast around i don't know
i don't know
i don't know what's going over there on
facebook again they're probably mad
they're probably
suppressing my freedom of speech
over on facebook they must distribute
my show
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know we'll find out what's going
on over at the books of face
but let's get to the uh trendy trends
and the tweety tweets here
well let's see let's go to the timeline
um uh you guys got any big stories that
you'd like to talk about today because i
got one i want to talk about now let's
make this a little bigger
i think this is uh
in the uh grand scheme
of the department of justice in january
6 select committee
this is very important news a batch of
john eastman emails from december 2020
shows his advice to state legislators
seeking to rescind biden's electors
including his suggestion that they
simply
re-tabulate the popular vote and put
trump at the top
so they wanted to uh
they wanted to steal the election
they wanted to cheat to win you know all
that [ __ ] that they'd say that democrats
did that they wanted democrats to do and
democrats are doing and all this [ __ ]
you know all that
that's that's what they were doing
like that's
what they were doing
and uh let's see if this is yeah here
here is the paragraph right here this
one right here it says uh
then having
done that math and the math that eastman
is talking about here is the [ __ ]
math where you would tabulate
you would you would recalculate the
figures you know just toss out some
ballots just toss them out what do you
need ballots for really honestly
you don't need ballots that's what this
[ __ ] movie two thousand mules is
about you heard this [ __ ] i'm sure
you've seen this in your comments and
they just probably comment two thousand
mules
that's what this is about this is about
this idea
that they would just toss out ballots
our ballots
the american people's ballots because
they don't like how they voted
right
john eastman says in this email then
having done that math
you'll be left with a significant trump
lead
that would bolster an argument for the
legislator adopting a slate of trump
electors
here's what he's telling this
pennsylvania congressman what you need
to do is you need to recount to where
trump wins
just just make it up just make the [ __ ]
up and he he he tries to make a case of
how to make it up
but just make it up just make up the
count doesn't matter how you do it as
long as trump has the lead it bolsters
the argument
for the legislator to adopt a slate of
trump electors so they're trying to
steal the pencil the state of
pennsylvania's the citizens vote
in pennsylvania
and he says perfectly within your
authority to do anyway so what he's
saying here is ah you can just you can
just do whatever you want you can
circumvent the people's vote in
pennsylvania
you don't have to follow rules you don't
have to file laws you can definitely
circumvent the laws
to make sure
that you get the outcome that you want
not what the people in the state of
pennsylvania want
he continues to say but now bolstered by
an untainted popular vote
he has the balls to say untainted
popular vote
in other words they know trump did not
win the popular vote folks
they know it
trump did not win the popular vote
and that's what he is admitting one
thing he's admitting in this [ __ ]
email here
the most significant part of this email
is the next sentence
eastman continues to say after you've
stolen the vote after you've
re-tabulated and recalculated and lied
about
who voted for who
he says that would help provide
some
cover
provide some cover
what the [ __ ] does that mean
what does it mean provide some cover
sounds like someone's committing crimes
and they're trying to hide it
seems kind of significant to me
uh so these this is the email and i've
retweeted this from kyle
here we'll give him kyle credit
for posting the entire entirety of the
email um this is seems to be one of the
damning emails in this batch of emails
now but i believe these emails are the
ones
if you recall we've been talking about
it a lot here on the tony michaels
podcast because it's very significant
this is part of the batch
that was seen by judge carter in
california where judge carter basically
lays out that this is not attorney
client privilege and i'm not sure if
this is
a forward or what
it's to a pennsylvania congressman so
i'm not sure where this is tied in
um to these emails but this email is
being released this morning that
is an obvious coup attempt
he's saying steal the vote from the
voters who cares about how they voted
[ __ ] them
just circumvent their vote
undo it
count them how you want
do it the way you want to do it
um
mayo tweets if
it feels like
it was just yesterday that i found out
trump thought china had a hurricane gun
did you hear this [ __ ] story
did you hear this [ __ ]
another another goddamn mark esper drop
is that i guess because there were so
many hurricanes you know because i don't
know like global warming
climate change
trump trump assumed what can't be that
you know science is wrong on every level
even when you're talking about injecting
bleach into your veins science just as
the science is out on that
he he surmised that china
had a hurricane gun and they were using
a nuns
can you [ __ ] even imagine
in our modern history
2020 2016 2022
in our modern age
that someone
would see the movie sharknado
and believe that that shit's real
right
that's hard to believe that's hard to
surmise
that's really hard to fathom
now think about it in this context
that person who believes that sharknado
is real
becomes the president of the united
states
believes it sharknado's a hurricane gun
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
no this goddamn buffoon thank you thank
you mail
now true socials back in the news if you
know now let's see if we can find uh
something on true social
i thought i just saw something anyways
the true socials back in the news here's
what's going on
uh elon musk you know
um
announced yeah well he was in an
interview yesterday and he said
something about being
[Music]
being
being being wanting to reinstate trump's
account on twitter well the problem is
is that elon musk doesn't [ __ ] own
twitter
he doesn't own it yet and i have
surmised for weeks that he won't i don't
think he'll own twitter it's all
[ __ ]
elon musk is full of [ __ ] [ __ ] always
has been always will be
oh here's joe's take that's that's what
i was saying earlier
joe's take on it was
um true social the town square of world
the world god damn it there we go true
social the town square for worlds
rejects
we'll read ron's tweet that she was
responding to here
uh ron had a uh a video here
and we'll play this of devin nunes let's
listen to what devin has to say about
elon musk
reinstating trump's account elon musk
cannot reinstate trump's account he
doesn't own twitter he's not going to
let's listen what we're trying to do
twitter is an old platform it's a pr
wire for elitists for blue checkers for
journalists for fake news oh my god
this is the [ __ ] this is the crazy ass
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
for elitist and journalist and
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is he talking about have
you ever have you ever been in the
comments with an elitist
are they just a [ __ ] talker a [ __ ]
talking troll
really honestly twitter's just a [ __ ]
swamp of [ __ ] talking trolls devin nunes
and it's an old platform oh god it's old
and worn out there's just no one on
there
now [ __ ] this guy it's for hollywood
celebrities what we're doing over at
true social is we're trying to make
social media fun again and the advantage
that we have making social media fun
again
you
ever are you [ __ ] me
this is his cell
he wants us to go over to true social
because he thinks true social is gonna
make social media fun again
does he mean does he mean making sure
that people don't see the truth ah [ __ ]
that that that true stuff
that stuff about facts and how [ __ ]
actually works ah god damn that's not
fun at all it's not fun to listen
it's not fun to listen to facts it's not
fun to hear the truth come over to true
social
where truth is our enemy
and lies are your friend
and we'll make we'll make disinformation
fun again
we have millions of americans who have
been banned or censored on the other
platforms yeah yeah they've been banned
or censored because they broke the terms
of service you [ __ ] chucklehead
braun here says on this post he said
devin nunes says true social is better
than twitter
because they have millions of people who
have been banned from other platforms
while twitter was has just elitist
journalists fake news and hollywood
celebrities
because you know hollywood celebrities
attract no attention
oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] gay
true social
what do you call it tooth tooth central
to
central speaking of uh two central and
true social and social media
we have our uh our local social media
expert here
uh co-host and executive producer
extraordinaire gabe sanchez gabe good
morning good morning have you
have you seen the uh did you watch the
devin nunes clip of him talking about
how uh twitter twitter is just old and
worn out gabe true social is the new
thing and there's no hollywood elites
there's no hollywood celebrities on
through social which makes it good i
wonder why
i wonder why
i feel like truth social is like a
tumbleweed in a desert right now just
going past this old western town
nobody's there the place is dried up
and anyone who's still living there
is
i don't know someone coming by to take a
photo for
for the instagrams right you know
it sounds like it's drier than ben
shapiro's wife's private party it really
does
boom shakalaka
boom chuckalacka we need we need we need
that sound effect boom yeah we should
get a whole sound board just for the
the morning shock jock radio
i think you're like whammy you know
you're just like yeah oh yeah we gotta
have a whammy and then you gotta have
the fart sounds yeah the bird sounds and
then you gotta i've got a sound board
here we're just we're just we're working
on getting some software that would pump
the sounds through the right right now
it's on manual so yeah you know you got
to do with your mouth whammy
boom chuckalucka
[Laughter]
oh man
these chuckleheads did you see the stuff
i sent you on your favorite guy nick
nick fuentes
uh no i didn't even get to watch it
watch this oh great
that is fantastic
oh buddy are we gonna watch this stuff
let me see if i can this is what happens
when you are two hours ahead of me you
get one i know
stuff in the morning and i gotta catch
what happens folks is gabe gabe lives in
that hollywood elite area yeah we don't
have twitter social out here so twitter
the twitterverse of los angeles yeah we
know all these we don't get truth social
out here so that means that we're not
getting the truth right you're not
getting the the truth so he's two hours
behind me in the morning but the the
thing is is this morning i was really i
was really sending texts to wake him up
because i was trying to get our
thumbnail gabe does all of our art here
and uh that the great thumbnails that
you guys get to see on youtube and
twitter uh gabe gabe makes those in the
morning that's the first thing he does
he he doesn't even take a piss first
before he starts
i don't get a meal all right lucky i
have a glass of water right now that's
what tony allows me to do in that i
gotta i gotta drag him out of bed yeah
just to get him to make a thing unlocks
the shackles and then says all right
make me that thumbnail
get the thumbnail [ __ ] i mean here's
the thing this morning i really i was
really worried because we got i mean it
was like 20 minutes after yeah and i'm
like i still haven't heard from him i'm
sending him gifts like wake up where are
you
someone get a hold of the game
true story i did oversleep this morning
i uh did you i went to sl here
to give everyone context the night
before yeah i know what happened thank
you i know you're going to tell lies no
i'm going to tell the truth
too much of that streaming soda water is
probably been drinking
not last night but the night before what
ended up happening was i was up to like
three or four i was i'm trying to get
back into the rhythm like filming videos
every day right and i filmed one um
two nights ago this and this maybe may
or may not be the chalk video is it no
no that was i was writing last night i'm
gonna film that one today okay okay okay
after
after this uh right the show but what
ended up happening was last night i went
to bed writing
the
i don't want to give away the name
of
these cops
it's because they're they're essentially
they're chalk cops and they show up to
the scene at susan collins that's the
whole premise right right right and
that's we've seen we've seen yesterday
that susan collins had called the cops
because right exactly
this is the what happened kind of moment
because that's what i do it's always
like this is this is the exclusive
footage yeah this is exclusive footage
between
these chalk cops and other cops on the
scene
uh or rather at the choc scene not the
crime scene but at the chock scene right
um
so i was writing it last night and i was
in bed and i was like typing out
oh so you're falling asleep i'm falling
asleep trying to get like i was like oh
how am i gonna try to get one more line
one and i was like i was like i know the
last line i want this cop to give but i
need to like have some bridge between
this part and this part and then i was
like okay i'm just gonna close my eyes
and i'm gonna just like imagine this in
my head and then boom out i'm out i'm
out but the night before i was up till
three or four a.m because i was talking
or i was i was filming another video
that has to do with a bunch of eligible
bachelors uh from the republican party
yeah these mega men
these matches these these magnificent
that's perfect because that is exactly
what we're going to talk about with this
nick fuentes thing i know because you
haven't seen this yet this is
your favorite guy nick fuentes oh yeah
yeah um you know apparently he's feuding
with his former uh treasury secretary of
the america first foundation
you know that oh it's a foundation now
oh yeah nazis have foundations gabe they
have foundations they don't just protest
in front of disney world they have
foundations yeah i mean trump had one
but that one got closed well
well
[Laughter]
nick available has a thread here
and jaden mcneal
is the uh is the young man's name
who was the former treasurer and nick
says here he recently resigned his
treasure from the america first
foundation
which is run by white nationalists and
nazi nick didn't say nazi that is my
words right nick fuentes
he's a nazi yeah he's a nazi it's this
idea that he's not as ridiculous if he
would like to
uh you know defend himself as not a nazi
feel free to come on the show yeah nick
is welcome nick is definitely welcome to
come on the show and i will eat his
[ __ ] lunch
and we will call him a nazi to his face
you will watch it and nick so if you're
out there and you're you're
feeling spry come on the show i'll call
you nazi to your face uh mcneil has this
is what nick says nick writes mcneal has
since leveled a lot of accusations
about fuentes that's right gabe there's
accusations from mcneil
about fuentes but the two videos i'm
about to post in this thread seem pretty
serious
so there's a couple posts here now
obviously
uh this jaden mcneal
uh this former treasurer
of
of the uh
of the america first nazi foundation
right
um
he apparently
was not actually the treasurer is what
he claims and what i mean by that is he
was kind of like a a fake treasure you
know just like on paper type stuff oh
okay uh nick here says in a tell-all
interview friday
on the live streaming show keno casino
which is filled full of a bunch of
really i mean it really seems like
um
stand-up individuals personalities that
are you know professional it
professionalism is definitely
their motto at no casino anyways jaden
mcneil says said
nick writes he was mostly a treasurer in
name only
he alleged that nick fuentes kept him
and a fellow board member michelle
mulkin you know who michelle mulkin is
no okay
board member michelle mulkin in the dark
on the america first foundation look up
michelle malkin while we watch this
video so if you see up here in the in
the right left hand corner the young man
with the pair of glasses the skinny guy
with the with the blue square on his
shirt this is the the former
treasurer of the america first nazi
foundation jaden mcneill um this guy
down here his name is pp apparently
that's his name nice yeah and then um
hal is over here um it says suey it's
not actually a video of him and then the
guy down here his name is you i i guess
it just he forgot to type his name in
and he just it said you so
right
right um uh so michelle malkin
uh is an american conservative political
commentator all right go ahead sorry she
was a fox news uh
uh contributor and a2020 joined newsmax
tv
she's written seven books and founded
the conservative website twitchy and hot
air don't go to those around 2019 malkin
began to publicly support members of the
extreme right including nick fuentes
malkin has faced criticism from
journalists and activists organizations
for association with white nationalist
nationalist neo-nazis and
uh groipers which is the
anti-semitic group right grapers yeah
aren't they the ones that you know it's
hard to tell what these are
folks i know they're like internet
trolls white
uh including nick fuentes identity
europa leader patrick casey in november
29 she was dropped by conservative
organization
uh young america's foundation citing her
support for individuals associated with
anti-semitism of course and white
nationalism so uh kathy thank you for
the super chat uh she says we need more
chalk
let's chalk these sons of [ __ ] i
agree with you uh don't don't listen to
the advice of anyone who says oh don't
go protest no protest the [ __ ] out of
these sons of [ __ ] that's what you
need to do
um gabe this this graphic with the super
chat graphic is fantastic i hope
everyone likes it we should come up with
some more of these yeah yeah i've got a
i've got another one uh we talked about
one with uh with ted cruz oh ooh
everyone out there ted cruz animations
coming soon yeah maybe maybe a degree
maybe a dancing trump one i don't know
baby
so here let's listen in on um this the
former treasurer of nick fuentes now
remember gabe nick fuentes is the the
messaging god of the gqp uh marjorie
taylor green loves to go to his rallies
they say america first all the time
america first america first america
first america first merrick first
america first hell it was [ __ ]
trending this morning because some
[ __ ] dumbass in america first hat was
uh who was wearing some kind of [ __ ]
fdny bomber jacket was yelling that
women didn't have the choice that he was
going to implant his seed in them and he
was going to make them have his baby is
what he was saying um that type america
purse type stuff you know patriotic type
stuff gabe patriotic stuff
but here is here is this jaden mcneil
let's listen into these
to this weird conversation if i was
making money doing that stuff
but i would ask
you were the treasurer of america first
right right so what did that entail and
were you not paid for that
um well so initially when he pitched
that to me it was before i moved to
chicago and he's like i just need two
basically dox people because it's all
public records so here's what he's
saying he's saying that
he just needs someone on paper to show
that he's the treasurer apparently that
nick fuentes is from chicago is that
right gabe uh i don't know we never
crossed paths when i was living i
believe nick fuentes is is from chicago
right because uh yeah yeah i remember
that being the case because
uh when
he had the video of like
i believe it was him or charlie kirk i
forget which one
aren't they both from
yes nick pointers is from chicago but
also let me see if charlie kirk where is
he from because every charlotte from
chicago suburb as well well he lived
there at one point right right because
uh
he was yeah arlington heights which is
just a suburb um but these people who
are like especially charlie kirk were
like oh you know like we're you know i
the whole the whole argument that he's
making about the hot tall skyscrapers
and more liberal versus you know right
right yeah
right right and i'm just like uh dude
you you lived in arlington heights what
right what what dirt describe describe
describe arlington heights right people
who don't know
both of these guys
are making claims that they understand
the real working man right and uh you
mean nick winters and and charlie kirk
yeah yeah and
they could be
you know
they are so far from the truth right but
anyway little side story there uh never
encounter nick fuentes in chicago
um
what is arlington heights like though
what is it like it's oh money
right
it's like a cookie cutter or suburb but
okay so they got some they got some
buildings over three three stories tall
in arlington yeah they've got probably
some commercial high rise that's like
hey come to the business
district of our town charlie kirk so
let's get back to this jaden mcneil he
says he was just the treasure on paper
of course
um let's listen to what else he has to
say out of the dirty he also just said
he won because he was there to dox
people no no no no he's it was just a
doc's thing oh he's saying just on just
it got it got it it's all all all nick
fuentes needs is someone on the
documents guys
here we go i moved to chicago and he's
like i just need two
basically docs people because it's all
public records so in other words he just
needs two people on record on public
record for documentation to show that
someone else is in charge of the
finances right yeah yeah um of people
that
people that can be on the board
essentially you're not gonna have to do
anything uh so me and michelle were on
the board and here he's talking about
michelle which is michelle mulkin who is
on the board of of the america first
nazi foundation
michelle malkin and uh he told me you
know you don't have to do anything
whatever but with the treasure um
position it was him and his assistant
that dealt with all the money and uh it
was basically like i was just
i was just giving a few papers to sign
so in other words
well it is fraud
i mean to some degree now rather it's a
criminal or not i don't you know i don't
know i don't know the the these i don't
know if he's got a you know an illinois
llc it's a 501c3 is what it is excuse me
right so there's so there's non-profit
the american first foundation is a 501c3
so it's a so it's a non-profit filing
um and of course you know non-profit not
nazis are non-profit yeah they're
non-profit organizations these nazi
organizations i mean they're you know
they're charity they're [ __ ] charity
yeah and they're two people who don't
know what type of work
right exactly if you if folks don't know
what 501c3 is it's just a tax
designation for a non-profit or what
some would consider a charity meaning
you get money to give away you're not
you're not um you're not trying to have
a margin i mean obviously now the 501c3
has employees they pay their employees
you know there is overhead in these in
these organizations and to give you a
good example of a 501c3 it might be like
a
oh like an animal shelter in your town
right they might be a 501c3 where they
collect money from the public to try to
you know help uh animals get homes and
make sure that that stray animals have a
place to sleep and are fed um and try to
try to control any kind of um you know
shenanigans that happens when people
don't take care of their animals so so
that that would be an example like a 501
c 3 or maybe even like a a food bank
or a vfw or a knights of columbus you
know people who collect money to give to
charity um those sorts of things right
nick fuentes america's first nazi
foundation is a 501c3 and when he filed
that paperwork what what uh jayden
mcneil is saying here his former
treasury
treasurer of that foundation
is saying that he was just documents
that nick fuentes and his assistant were
actually the ones that were in control
of it he wasn't actually and then the pp
guy i can't believe i had to say this
but the guy named peepee down here uh
ask him a um a sort of a decent question
he basically said so you just signed a
few papers you weren't actually the
treasurer you just signed a few papers
to make sure that it looked like you
were let's let's finish um they did
there wasn't too many like i will say
that uh i was basically like i'm not a i
know i sound like a
[ __ ] i'm not a patsy you sound a
little bit like a fantastic paper
obviously he uses a defensive word he
says i sound like a dumb [ __ ] which
again um
nick fuentes
picked this guy so hand picked him to be
his treasure so that doesn't say much
about jaden here obviously
did you read like any of it or you wrote
no i did i did read through it um it
wasn't like anything super sketched or
anything that i saw it was basically
just i was signing off um
for
the registrations to raise money in
certain states it wasn't anything like
crazy so not a big
so so so what he's saying here is that
oh it's not a big deal and the reason
why it's not a big deal
is because i just signed off the
original registration of where our
quote-unquote charitable foundation
would raise money right and i'm not
actually the treasurer i'm going to give
nick some credit here thanks for your
your video um and there's another video
here
um and and then i want to show you a
nick fuentes video of nick says because
it's hilarious i just want to show it
just because nick fuentes is a [ __ ]
and i want to drag him because he's he's
a a [ __ ] but let's listen to jaden here
and ppu and hal
and that's really why i came out with
the resignation to begin with is because
uh
i
wasn't really i didn't have anything to
do with it i saw some
sort i heard some things way later that
i had no idea was going on inside the
organization that like dropped in a
couple of hit pieces i didn't even know
about that stuff um and i'm like yeah i
want nothing to do with this
obviously nick's like insane um
and he has all my information
and i just wanted to step away i just
wanted to put it out there publicly like
i have nothing to do with this because i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on
behind the scenes there so this is
supposed to be the treasure and he has
no idea where the money's going
um so
in the audience might be saying why why
is this important why is this kid here
important why is this important tony to
the national conversation these are the
people who are running the pro
republican party's messaging apparatus
yeah they are pushing pushing america
first messaging this is the reason why
we have these dumb bucks showing up at
these protests in the american first
hats telling women that they're going to
impregnate them
and they're going to have to carry their
baby to term this is why marjorie taylor
green goes on the house floor folks this
is a united states congresswoman who
listens to these [ __ ] people's
garbage and spews it on our house floor
this is very vital and important at
where they are getting this garbage from
everyone yeah maybe it's insignificant
it's not part of the news the reason why
it's not it's because they don't want it
to be part of the news right the
republican party does not want to be
associated with nick fuentes that's why
they get so pissed off so pissed off
when lauren beaubert or paul gosar or
andy biggs or marjorie taylor green have
anything to do with these [ __ ] morons
they get [ __ ] pissed just like
they're
dumping on madison gawthorne because he
continues and continues to talk about
america first and america first and they
want they want the america first
messaging they want the nazis to vote
for him they just don't want it to
appear that the nazis are in control of
their messaging and they are folks ron
desantis has his supporters who are
waving nazi flags in front of disney
world probably as we speak
and it is nazis that are running this
messaging and they're not i'm not saying
like
hyperbolically not right these people
are nazis they are neo-nazis they are
white supremacists they don't they do
not care
if they are outed like that that don't
give a [ __ ] they want to be known
as anti-semites they clearly want to be
known that way i mean nick fuentes is
also the guy that if anyone remembers
last year he was the one that was using
the baking cookies analogy
in comparison to the holocaust and
saying how
that you know oh well it's got to be
fake because if there was something to
happen and you did bake this many
cookies then you would at least find the
ovens like this is the type of
disgusting person that the republicans
are listening to and also pushing like
you said they are just regurgitating
these same talking points on the house
floor it's as bad as matt gates trying
to say i've got this thumb drive with
all the content right hunter biden's
laptop and i want to enter this into the
record like that's the type of [ __ ]
where it's like oh yeah great we're just
going to enter some random [ __ ] that's
not validated right or cited or actually
has any sort of uh uh you know
check on it before we just like throw it
in there this is the type of stuff you
got lauren bobert marjorie taylor green
matt gates all these paul gosar all
these people
who are just regurgitating this stuff
and then it's it like you said it goes
in a house record or it goes down to the
record and then other people start
talking about it like that right it's on
fox news newsmax and then the former guy
the [ __ ] cheeto dust mobster starts
saying people say this people say that
and then sean hannity says it and then
tucker carlson says exactly it's it's
absolutely and listen the other thing
that nick fuentes does people is he
[ __ ] loves
putin he loves putin he loves putin
because he wants a murderous dictator to
murder the people that he doesn't like
that's the whole point that's the whole
point of authoritarianism is to get rid
of the others the people that aren't you
that you don't like it's craziness now
listen listen to what jaden says here uh
rhonda says it's revenge of the nerds um
it's like revenge of the nerds on on
nazi steroids around it but i agree with
you
[Laughter]
revenge of the turds revenge of the
church there you go kelly
she updates the revenge of the turds but
let's listen to what the revenge of the
turds has to say here
nick didn't tell me a lot of things that
were going on behind the scenes while
using my name he obviously has like all
my information like all of my
information um obviously jayden is uh
very uh uh scared of being doxed here
and he thinks nick will do that and one
of your concerns about this is that
you're being threatened with your social
security number being released yeah i
mean that yeah i was i was hinting at
that yeah it's so he has my social
security number and other stuff like
that and i just want i don't know what
he gets up to with his with his the
finances of this foundation but i wanted
to be really concerned that all jayden
with the legality of any of this like
are you concerned it might come back on
you
um i mean
not super concerned but also i know how
nick operates i don't know how much i
want to get into it because he is like
threatening so obviously obviously there
was some shady [ __ ] going on um at the
america america first nazi foundation
and folks again you might look at this
and go who are these these these whipper
snappers these whipper snappers why is
it important they literally are driving
the message of marjory taylor green
lauren beauberg matt gatz paul gozar and
ultimately the america first movement in
this country which is the maga movement
it is the manga movement it is an arm of
the maga movement yeah this is super
important but also the fact that that
someone like nick fuentes has that much
influence
over
our politics is a very dangerous thing
right like you could say rush limbaugh
also like you know offered the the right
their talking points for each day in
terms of what they should be
riled up and raged about and and mad
but for someone like this nick fuentes
who is an outright you know he is a
white nationalist nazi anti-semitic
guy that is that is speaking out these
vile things
and then it says oh yeah you know what
the political scene will be very
influenced by this guy so that we'll we
will continue to say what he says in a
public forum
we will take it outside of this only
right-wing 4chan rumble
uh environment and outbreak explain
explain be honest with 4chan and rumble
is because some people may not know what
4chan and rumble is this is like the
dark web the the right wing
you know the true social of youtube
and and and reddit right right yeah well
so rumble is a is a video hosting site
it's where you find all of his videos
you'll find rsbn you'll find all the
stuff that like you know normal places
won't
you just won't find right wing you know
fascist uh
white nationalist nazi content it's the
free speech platform where literally
anything is okay we try to stream our
show and see how long it takes them to
you know i was considering that recently
if we had the ability to just like
upload episodes it would be this i would
i would be curious because true social
is also using rumble as their video um
streaming
support and i was debating you know
based on what your experience was like
just
showing a a video of of donald trump
saying yeah i posted one video i posted
one video so i'm thinking like what if
we were to post a show up there and see
how quickly we just get tossed out so
yeah
i mean hey you know i'm i'm for it i'm
for it but uh 4chan is an anonymous site
uh where
you find a lot of these right-wing nut
jobs on there you know q
q was a big part or rather 4chan was a
big part of q in terms of how it
came to be so you had people who were on
there again anonymous
uh
just anything goes type forums you've
got um you know
there's child porn that there's found on
there there's all sorts of stuff the
disgusting stuff that's found on 4chan
because it is truly a free speech
platform so anything goes without it
was it 4chan or 8chan which one came
first
4chan i believe and then 8chan was next
or something like that because there's a
lot of these type sites right right
right right there's like telegram
there's a there's a lot of these
right-wing
um networks where there's nazi [ __ ] here
while you're looking that up here's
jaden um here
talking about 4chan and then 8chan and
so it's 2014 8chan but that was that
came out of the gamergate controversy
which is the right whole other thing
right the whole another half hour that
we would have right exactly here is
jaden talking about him he's considering
outing the donors which is very
significant and listen to the name that
he brings [ __ ] it i'm gonna burn it all
down right well right but listen to the
name that he brings up here gabe um
who are his big donors i don't want to
disclose any of that that's uh i mean if
he wants to keep pushing and pushing and
pushing we could do a whole another
keynote casino frankly um
you would think
two weeks in two weeks in the dude will
just shut his [ __ ] mouth um but gosar
said it best he doesn't know how to and
that's why we're still doing this whole
thing
so you
you guys caught the name there yeah the
name was goes-r um that name may sound
familiar to you because
paul gosar is a congressman from arizona
who is a huge nick fuentes fan
yeah but they have in here they had a
whole thing last year it was like right
sit down come see us
talk [ __ ] one he goes to all his nazi
rallies and everything and speaks for
him but apparently jaden here is saying
that paul gozar talks [ __ ] behind nick
fuentes's back is what he's saying and i
guess jaden here is considering if nick
fuentes keeps pushing to out his donors
which i i don't know i don't again i
don't know the laws of the 501c3 and
what laws jaden is bound to here yeah
but jaden if you can hear my voice jaden
if you can hear my voice
you're a welcome your dumbass is welcome
anytime
on my show any time you would like you
just you just give me a holler and we
will get you on here and we will ask you
the real questions that america needs to
know about what you know so let's finish
what jayden has to say here and then i
want to show you this crazy video from
nick fuentes yeah um
13 days later or however long it's been
because
uh i resigned as treasurer
i resigned from treasurer he claims he
fired me not true um i had this thing
typed up weeks in advance was planned to
drop it when i left um
he spurged out on twitter he asked me to
come sign something never said never
said what that thing was but i at the
time was like i'm
yeah it's just a bunch of nonsense now
the thing here is gabe that that a lot
of people again are like why is this
significant what do i give a [ __ ] yeah
here's the thing folks
this is the same type of [ __ ] talk that
was happening before january 6
when they were trying to overthrow our
government they were on these [ __ ]
weird ass [ __ ] social media sites
they were out there
pumping this message really trying hard
and here's here's one of them here's
nick fuentes himself on his show you see
the af down here it does not stand for
as [ __ ] yeah usually it's like uh
i think it stands for nazi as [ __ ] right
night's nazi as [ __ ] that might be it
not me as [ __ ] or or america first yeah
yeah or america first nazi foundation
yeah but here is nick fuentes's take on
no listen to this game this is his take
because he has the nativity scene there
in the nutcracker it looks like it
appears this was around christmas
sometime
nick poison test is going to explain to
you here why men having sex with women
is gay i'm i'm not kidding you i know
that sounds weird
but here is the logic and this is this
is nick fuentes in a nutshell i'm going
to show you one more video of him before
we move on to a break but let's listen
to this video here we'll listen to part
of it i i can't play it all it's it's
that bad but let's listen what people
calling me gay because i've never had a
girlfriend
i think if anything if anything it makes
me less gay if anything it makes me not
gay as opposed to less gay not that
there's any gay but it makes me not gay
well because think about he seems really
uncomfortable about being yeah he's like
guys guys
listen
i'm less gay right like right like it's
like whether he's asexual or not he's
just like oh look dude i've never i've
never [ __ ] a woman no this is not to
say right whatever you know i'm not
going to go into that but so the context
of this though is gabe that he was on an
interview and someone asked him if he's
ever been with a woman and he said no
yeah
right yeah i mean in that in that a
video that exists i believe let me look
it up
i think he talks about here let's listen
you know a gay person gay people do date
girls all the time
real
and when i said on elijah shave for
shelter
a live shaffer show
and here's what he says in a romantic
relationship have you ever had sex with
a girl and i said no
if you name-searched me on twitter as i
always do
he searches himself on twitter is that
what he just said sounds like ted
cruz had crews searching for himself
during the the the jack the
judge jackson hearings he goes is that
so you could block people i don't know
what people are saying about me oh
cancun cruise block block block block
uh nick fuentes isn't even on twitter
right he must have an alternative oh no
he got kicked off of
he got kicked off of twitter but he's
gotta have a soccer account if he's on
there but oh i guess you can search if
you don't have an account yeah search
you still be a lurker right
is that right you can lurk around
twitter if you don't have an account yes
okay yeah yeah i mean i think they're
yeah yeah for the most part it's pretty
much free let's listen to
what this bonehead says about having
having sex with a woman a man having sex
with a woman is gay he clearly does not
understand
words but let's listen people are coming
out and saying i've had more girlfriends
than nick i've i've had texted more
girls than nick
so like i said last week
not only is not only is that thinking
flawed
but actually it's the reverse that
actually makes me
really
more heterosexual than anybody if if
we're being if we're really being honest
never having a girlfriend and never
having sex with a woman
really makes you more heterosexual
because honestly
dating women is gay
having sex with women is gay
okay okay okay i'm and i'm gonna stop
here because i waited i found another
video okay yeah send me a link from
right wing watch
here here's the uh the thing here
obviously nick fuentes
hates women
yeah he hates me
hates
women oh
hates him
probably probably more than he hates
jewish yeah yeah
i mean here's the thing so do you think
do you think uh
i mean elon musk was saying he was going
to bring trump back to twitter not that
trump said he would come back to twitter
but do you think that he would because
that's the news right that's very easy
remember also people that
out of the straight from the horse's
mouth yesterday as tony and i have been
saying he does not own twitter right for
that i guy out there who said little
semantics no it's let's be approved he
currently has a lawsuit a class-action
lawsuit against himself as well as the
other members of twitter by the orlando
police pension fund back the blue baby
uh so
in this moment
uh he does not own twitter but he has
said he would bring trump back and now
does that mean he would also bring nick
fuentes back because he said this is
over reaching
that's a good point
that's a good point he may he may bring
him back let's um you say right wing
watch has a tweet here it says a woman
tried to flirt with nick fuentes during
a live stream uh last night and it
resulted in him having a 10-minute
meltdown is this 10 minute video no no
this is the three minute that's a minute
oh okay to the end of hear him envision
this scenario in which he might be
appropriate for him to flirt so this is
this is january but uh yeah well let's
listen to how he how he responds to
someone flirting to him
in uh in his live chat
what part of what you
know about me would make you think that
i would want to be propositioned by a
woman
much less
okay first off first off here we see the
rc cola here yep and um that that really
uh gabe this is us all of uh just
any part of this
because he's he's drinking who in the
[ __ ]
who in the right [ __ ] mind
chooses to drink rc coal yeah no pepsi
no coke not even a generic store brand
from lipstick
[ __ ]
rc cola gabe this is a crime here no
okay let's listen to this molestation
what it has to say less
in the super chats no less what part of
you
or what part of me would make you think
that i would want a girl
to say uh you know to to to ask me out
on a date
what what i'm not gonna be asked out i
will do the asking out
you know people look at me and they
think like oh so they had to cut it was
so long that they had to cut yeah so
it's like the it's the
setup and then it's how he's gonna get
out of this and say how he
should be allowed to flirt right okay
well he's like this
alex p keaton like goodie two shoes
wholesome chunky ten thousand it's like
nah i'm a little bit more complicated
than like wanting a girl in a sundress
to just lay my suits out and i wear a
fedora and smoke a pipe and go hey honey
we're larping like it's a 1950s like
that's just so insulting i have a little
bit it's called depth okay it's called
death i have a little bit more anyone
who drinks rc cola and anyone who out
there who is listening to us right now
he's our listeners that drinks rc cola i
hate to tell you
you have no depth like you can't even
get you can't even figure out that
coca-cola and pepsi is better than rnc
cola come on
come on come on this is ridiculous more
depth to my character than just i'm some
kind of like sitcom character
i'm sort of playing an important role
in world history here and the idea that
you know some some
silly girl
online like i'm going to be in direct
messages just sort of being like funny
and flirty and
fun it's just
not me it's just not going to happen
like i said i'm trying to think of i'm
trying to think of a scenario where it
would be acceptable because so some
people say oh that means you're gay and
it's like well no because
it's it's not that it's just it's more
the setting there because there's a few
scenarios where it would be acceptable
like i said
you know if it was a girl who was
working for me you know like hitler in
that movie downfall when he's like oh he
loves to bring up hitler by the way yeah
any chance this [ __ ] gets to
bring up hitler especially especially
when he's hating on him some women like
when he's hating on him some women he
loves to throw in the hitler reference
it's juicy right like that makes that
makes your misogyny even that more manly
right right gabe i mean more manly than
tanning your balls either oh yeah
totally way way more manly when you
bring up hitler while you're bashing on
women
jesus christ reviewing secretaries like
that that's a setting where it like
makes a little bit more sense
what part of jesus christ so basically
the only scenario that is acceptable for
another for a woman
to openly hit on nick fuentes uh would
be in a setting where he
or where where the woman is the
subordinate right exactly you know i
like the example you know like the
secretary who worked for hitler in that
movie you know i'm hitler in this
scenario like he's literally saying i'm
hitler in the scenario now let's listen
to one more clip and we played this
several times and i'm gonna keep playing
this [ __ ] over i feel like you
should over again
we should cut up a clip that is just
that on a repeat for like 30 seconds
right well and we should we could remix
it too to like some music or something
because nick fuentes this is no i don't
want to make it i don't want to make it
enjoyable music though i want to make oh
you want to make it really yeah well i
mean like it's you know it's it's rough
to the [ __ ]
right to hear it you know well it's it's
gross as [ __ ] because he's gross as [ __ ]
and maybe that's what the af gross nazi
as [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay let's listen to what nick fuentes
thinks if a woman
has an abortion what he thinks should
happen to her the woman should be put in
jail too they should all go to jail a
hundred years for the doctor a thousand
years for the woman that's what i say he
wants a thousand years in prison for a
woman
if she were to have a medical procedure
to save her life
nick fuentes is all such a feminist oh
my god oh my god he's so straight
he's for women
that is true he's so so gay
yeah exactly he's so heterosexual that
he might be homosexual
he's like i'm not gay you're gay he's
like you know how gay you are you had
sex with women i have sex with men it's
like what i don't know what makes any
sense i'm telling you man i'm telling
you uh uh
jaden you're welcome to come on the show
and and out
out the donors
out the donors of the america first nazi
foundation and also if you'd like you
could tell us a little more about nick
fuentes's
views and his tendencies on
his weird
heterosexuality that he has i'm not
against anyone identifying however they
want and if you want to call yourself a
heterosexual
because to be frank with you
gabe a a straight man who doesn't have
sex with women is still a straight man
that doesn't and again nothing wrong if
you're asexual like that's your thing
whatever that's cool right whatever it
is really weird though that you go on
diatribes trying to prove how you're not
you're not something that you don't want
to someone to identify you as right like
it's really weird it's really strange
and it sends this projection signal nick
it really does
everyone stick around we're gonna have
more with the tweety tweets and trendy
trends as soon as we come back after
these messages stick around
right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
tony michaels podcast proud partner of
midas touch
broadcasting from youtube twitter and
twitch every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific
go to youtube type in the tony michaels
podcast
subscribe there we also simulcast to
minus touch facebook page holy smokes
and if you're over there on the books
gabe something's happening over on the
bookspace we're being suppressed
zuckerberg i think they i think
zuckerberg hated our title this morning
it was 40 billion to defeat putin which
we're going to talk about here in a
minute yeah um but i think zuckerberg's
really butthurt about our title this
morning so they're suppressing our
speech
we do not have the viewers
not into it i did notice that this
morning
they're not disturbing a lot of people
on the show
maybe we should maybe we should um
facebook if you're out there listening
zuckerberg if you're listening we might
we might go to true social and to rumble
where we have our freedom
of non-speech or speech or whatever
right um
we have some breaking news gabe oh yeah
you know this uh scott mcfarland uh has
a video here but he says the breaking
news is joe manchin is a no vote today
on the abortion rights legislation on
this of course
of course we know susan collins lisa
murkowski um [ __ ] in this cereal as well
a lot of people thought that they might
be able to count on lisa murkowski to
vote for these um
the h
excuse me
whpa
which stands for women health protection
act um to try to codify roe v wade uh
some have been saying oh well democrats
are overreaching what the [ __ ] are you
talking how in the [ __ ] can anyone say
that you're overreaching when you give
someone rights
what are you talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about hey
man you're giving you're giving women
too much control over their own bodies
okay my god way too far way too far
giving women way too many goddamn rights
but let's listen to what uh joe manchin
has to say about how he's a no vote it's
only 20 seconds here which is about
anything that joe manchin
says of legislation which i will not
going to be voting on actually
vote for today
i would vote for a roe v wade
qualification if it was today i was
hopeful for that but i found out
yesterday in caucus that wasn't going to
be
and you probably heard about that by now
why not change your position though i
mean you saw senator casey he
you know changed his view
so again this is the [ __ ] uh where
joe manchin is trying to say well this
goes way too far
way too far this doesn't just codify roe
v wait this gives women's rights past
roe v wade
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people
how are we even in a position here where
we have to we have to not only defend
women's rights but we have to defend
women's rights upon rights upon rights
like you at nope nope they get rights
gabe but they get the rights that we
tell them they can have you only get you
only get
so many rights you only get so many
rights just a little bit just a little
bit not a lot just a little bit enough
but not too much
so that's joe manchin's take um
katie porter is trending there's a lot
of breaking news now all of a sudden
yeah katie porter was like hey guys you
don't you haven't talked to any of your
constituents have you
well she's talking about uh she's
trending because of the uh skyracketing
grocery bills um and i bet she lays down
the law on inflation and how inflation's
working and who is benefiting and who is
actually responsible for it i'm sure but
the thing i want to go to is our title
today 40 billion to ukraine gabe
republicans are super [ __ ] pissed
super pissed that we're gonna give money
to get rid of their dictator that they
love they are [ __ ] pissed off about
this
they are super pissed and has something
to do with baby formula i haven't really
figured that out yet but has some have
you seen this have you seen this [ __ ]
i uh yeah when you sent me the stuff
about the when you sent me the video of
don jr with the baby formula thing i had
to look into it and then i figured out
what was going on oh man we gotta go
watch that [ __ ] but
uh i mean look
let's let's let's talk about this 40
billion right like right our country uh
would very much benefit from 40 billion
dollars okay in terms of
programs that we want to educate the
workforce or
uh reinvest in our communities like 40
billion can go a long way in the us and
i'm not saying that
you know
giving 40 about 40 billion dollars you
know is like oh it's so great but i mean
it's obviously a necessity to help them
protect themselves against putin
obviously the republicans don't want
that they want putin to win and just say
you know what's our land is or rather
what's what you thought was your land is
our land i mean it sounds very similar
to
your body
my choice right like if you look at it
that way right it's like your country
my my my country you know right um
again you know i think 40 billion
dollars go a long way republicans are
very anti the 40 billion dollars but i
also have not heard them give an
alternative solution to say one how do
we prevent this
uh
this just genocide in ukraine by by
putin but also if you have a problem
with 40 billion dollars because our vets
aren't getting it or
our homeless population isn't getting it
or
do something or yeah or or just the the
the lack of
proper nutrition
and available resources and communities
then offer something that actually does
that right again i i understand that
people are not are not happy and they're
upset because we gave them money maybe
maybe we want to uh
you know throw some money away from the
military they get a [ __ ] ton of money
not saying they don't need it but they
do have a lot of money right there's
other ways that i feel like we could
chip away at different budgets or
funding
that you could say okay you know what
actually we want to reinvest this in
these areas these these people need it
these you know these women need it right
if these men need it these families need
whatever it is
like you look at this and say
maybe
maybe you can find uh 40 billion here
under the carpet that's or in the couch
that just been hiding you know that you
stowed away to invest in something else
that you can put back in the country but
i've yet to see any sort of alternative
uh a solution or or say like well you
know he gave 40 billion here like
where else could it go right i don't see
proposal i don't see anyone i just see
like typical republican uh kind of
outrageous that's wrong that's wrong
that's wrong but i'm never gonna provide
you a solution well no that why would
they because here's the here's the rep
folks because this is gonna be the
narrative in the mainstream media this
is they're gonna do the bull side [ __ ]
with this 40 billion dollars they're
going to say oh well we have to spend 40
billion dollars to defeat putin but oh
boy that inflation thing is really going
to hurt inflation listen
if putin has his way and he gets rid of
western democracy don't [ __ ] worry
your head about inflation what would you
worry about inflation for if we didn't
have our country like literally if our
democracy and our country doesn't exist
what would you give a [ __ ] about
inflation for you don't have to worry
about gas prices if you let these
fascists take over our country and have
their fastest need you don't have to
worry about education anymore there is
there isn't going to be any yeah and
frankly if you're worried about food
prices they're going to decide who gets
the food and who doesn't are you worried
about the baby formula shortage because
there was a recall they're going to
decide who the [ __ ] gets baby formula
and even if there is baby formula
because why would there need to be baby
for him they gave god is supposed to
take care of all that stuff god takes
care of that [ __ ] we don't have to take
care of that [ __ ] god takes all we have
to make sure is that these women die by
carrying these babies to full term that
way we don't give them any kind of any
kind of food assistance whatsoever
republicans are the ones who have always
[ __ ] voted against wic against
[ __ ] snap they [ __ ] hate giving
money to anybody that isn't them that
isn't them
and and no better example here than the
buffoonery from booger sugar junior here
who has no [ __ ] idea what he's
talking about no [ __ ] clue what he's
talking about and he has a you know a
bunch of word salad i'm still maybe i'm
still trying to figure it out
i can only decipher some of this you
know so well it is once we once we
listen to it i'll be able to provide a
little bit of context you see this flag
up here i'm wondering who this flag is
from number one but the real question i
have about it's got to be some some
[ __ ] person
who grifted
all their money away
they went into bankruptcy and then they
were like oh don junior uh i don't have
any money to give your family anymore so
here i'm gonna give the commemorative
flag from my son who you know died
overseas or whatever it is right like
that's what i feel like that's because
the only people who get these flags are
those from family members that have been
lost and i don't know any [ __ ] trump
that i ever did willingly served in the
military
they're all [ __ ] bone spur draft
dodging
little snowflakes because that's what
they are right and uh
i'm just like
unless he bought here's the other
alternative he bought that [ __ ] on ebay
right well that could be you know what
else he bought on ebay what the [ __ ] is
this thing underneath the flag on the
shelf
what is that thing uh
is that a sex toy
it looks either between like a glass
sex toy right or a bong
right it could be i mean you gotta it's
like uh
it's like uh looks maybe like a sperm is
he free-basing coke out of this thing he
might be honestly i i don't know i know
do people steal freebase cocaine i don't
know i don't know if they do or not who
knows
uh here we go let's listen to booger
sugar junior here buckle in his cocaine
word sale into your butts
what we do not look away here listen to
what he says about [ __ ]
baby formula keep going they don't care
you're paying for it they get to reap
the rewards
who is who is your paying board who the
[ __ ] is he talking to
i mean we're still paying for the jobs
and tax bill that's right trump passed
in 2017 but whatever you know well is he
being the gop tax scam that they're
going to try to raise taxes on the
middle class is that what he's saying
the gop is going to tax you so you have
to pay for it is that what he's saying
because that's what they're trying to do
what a [ __ ] bonehead
um
yeah but it's it's russia's fault that
we have an inflationary crisis not uh
not ukraine right we have why does he
always refer to ukraine as the ukraine
you noticed that yeah the facebook right
the ukraine right i mean this is the
tony michaels podcast the interwebs but
but he says the ukraine every time he
refers to ukraine the ukraine in other
words he's saying it's not an actual
country i think that's what he's saying
is it's not an action it's the ukraine
territory right that is russia it's like
what is this oh it's the carolinas it's
right the dakotas right like right in
his mind just like you said it's not
it's a terrorist not an actual country
it's a property it's a territory
for putin right right
broken bridges disastrous roads yeah
because putin's smashing them with bombs
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking he's
like this this he's like the ukraine is
just falling apart it needs someone to
come in there and rebuild it and it's
like you dumb [ __ ] the guy that is that
you want to go in there is the one that
destroyed it he's the one that's bombing
medical wards and hospitals and killing
children i thought your goddamn party
was all for saving the children yeah
you're watching a guy and rooting a guy
that wants to kill innocent lives and
children doesn't seem so pro-life to me
you [ __ ]
homeless problems uh does that hold with
it literally
literally they are driving ukrainians
out of their homes because it is
war-torn because of the aggression and
war crimes that putin is committing but
if you think about it tony it's actually
very on brand because republicans will
make up a problem right they'll they'll
cause the problem sure and then be like
guys what is going on with this problem
over here it's like all these ukrainian
refugees
you look at you look at you look at the
income gap that has just
blown up since let's say you know
trickle down economics reagan or times
before that and you look at this income
gap where you could have a whole family
of four children two parents and one of
them was able to work and was and was
able to you know send them through
college and put food on a table all
these things now you look at 2022 where
people have more than two jobs to
support one kid and themselves and maybe
another adult who also has to work right
so you look at that and you say
there there is something that doesn't
make sense here right and why is it oh
it's because you wanted to
not tax the riches heavily you wanted to
uh you know
uh incorporate uh loopholes into
tax and jobs bills so you said you know
what the way that we can actually
reinvest in the community is if you get
rich people more money and kickbacks and
then you find out that they don't give
money so now you find out these people
are cutting more profits shaving down
wages and reducing the amount that they
actually invest in the company and the
employees and the community and now
you're saying the homelessness problem
we got this homelessness problems like
why do you think we [ __ ] have this
why do you think we have people sleeping
on the streets because shelters are full
they don't have resources they're
shutting down right they're they're
non-profits you know unlike nick fuentes
who's you know scamming and fr
and creating fraud these places don't
have money to actually keep the lights
on because the money's not coming in
because people that don't have money to
actually support and donate but then
you've got you've got [ __ ] don junior
over here is complaining about
homelessness and bridges down and these
people and these that are in ukraine
because it was a problem that that
[ __ ] putin created it's so much like
the republican party which is create a
problem
complain about the problem
don't actually offer a solution to the
problem you create right
exacerbate the problem you know create
more of a problem on top of the problem
let's listen to booger sugar here minus
robin says
putin is a baby killer and that's just
[ __ ] truth this is true at the border
right it would have taken a couple
billion like three or four billion to
finish the border wall stop the
humanitarian crisis no way we can't do
that but that's then ten times that in
addition to
what they've already sent to the ukraine
and maybe just maybe if we're lucky we
can avoid nuclear war with russia
guys to me it reads there's nothing
other than democrats trying to get their
kickbacks in before they lose power
uh it's absolutely sick okay and joe
biden
joe biden
is
the
the claim that two to three billion
would solve the border issue
i want to remind people that the border
the great magnificent border that trump
funded and also steve bannon defrauded
investors for big through a private
reason
campaign exactly right
and one that also donald trump anointed
i believe the the words were anointed
the project to be yes i approve that go
forward and said the word anointed i
believe so
but he you know he approved the project
this private funded project which then
later he's like i never i don't know
anything about that i don't know what
you're talking about who's steve bannon
who's
you see don jr says two to three billion
would solve the board of crisis that is
not true has anyone looked at the
[ __ ] landscape of the southern border
you have to [ __ ] build [ __ ] through
mountainous ranges which is just
forget about the [ __ ] river that's
right there i mean right yeah use a body
of water then exactly but if anyone
would actually go down to the southern
border you could look at the wall you
could literally cross over you could
look straight on down the wall be on be
in america and then walk two feet over
and be in mexico you look at the actual
border that trump has implemented in
these different areas because he was
solving the border crisis these
these walls these plat these these pot
these pylons or whatever of a fence are
falling apart they're rusting they're
falling down they're not great
people typical trump style yeah they're
like oh no one can ever scale these
things
easily i've seen videos on [ __ ] tick
tock of people that were like oh this is
how you could scale it not that they're
trying to go over but they're trying to
show you how easy it is to actually
climb up this [ __ ] right you make it you
just walk far enough you can walk around
it like exactly that's the thing you
walk far enough you get into the
mountainous areas boom there's just an
open gap you just kind of walk over no
big deal you'd have to climb the border
you just crossed it right and again i
mean what about the river that you can
swim across or wait you're like oh yeah
the rio grande no no you can't do that
[ __ ] yeah but it's the the claim again
this claim that two to three billion
would solve the border crisis issue no
that is not it at all unless you unless
you know don jr is talking about
spending two to three billion more
dollars to separate families and put
kids in cages that's what he's talking
about that's right see that that's the
thing that he's talking about what he
wants to do is separate babies from
their mothers so that way we don't have
to feed him formula because somehow he
brings this back to baby formula let's
let's listen tell the american people
that inflation is your top priority when
you're printing money out the wazoo to
send it to this this clown show
enough is enough let's put america first
let's maybe there it is there it is did
you hear it there's the nick went to his
messenger
folks there's this clown show that is
trying to defeat putin we're trying to
defeat putin because he's trying to
defeat democracy america first remember
america versus america first nazis nazis
nazis we get baby formula for our
children and our infants maybe let's
here here it is let's back this up again
listen to what he says here he goes from
america first to baby formula
enough is enough let's put america first
let's maybe get baby formula for our
children and our infants maybe let's
turn our oil pumps back on instead of
this insanity but no that's not going to
happen we all know it now
you need to lay off the [ __ ] coke
dude i mean just straight need to lay
off the coke what is okay so this baby
form the story and they're gonna they're
gonna run with this like the crt [ __ ]
right and the reason why they're picking
up this baby formula story is because
they have to appear that they love
babies like they have to because now now
that they don't
you you have a baby we'll help you
support it [ __ ] we'll give you the
baby formula so that you can you can you
know because here's the other thing he's
like oh you guys you know what you know
there's also a time in which you give
babies
baby formula versus breastfeeding and
you know but it's like why do you guys
want so much baby formulas because
you're trying to separate families and
the babies and you want only the you
know it's like oh whatever dude it's so
[ __ ] messed up but
go ahead go ahead
the reason that there's a shortage why
it's hard to find is because it's a
compound effect of supply chain chain
challenges right ones that have been
created by republicans and also
inflation right one again ones that
we're dealing with because uh trump
didn't act quick enough we had we found
ourselves in a recession um but there
was also a huge recall baby for him that
killed a couple children right and there
was a recall as well and that's part of
that change supply chain they had to
shut down the factory exactly for some
time to make sure that it it was safe
for children you know because
what's what's the use of making formula
safe let's just make it out i mean who
gives a [ __ ] really you gotta remember
what happened in china right the baby
formula there was out there that
actually killed children because they
were diluting
they were uh they were they were
basically trying to cut baby formula and
then the baby formula came out ended up
having
adverse effects on children and then
they had to shut it down i forget i
think it was like a few years ago uh
that happened but that was that was like
global coverage um because i forget how
far the reach was in terms of producing
baby formula but i know especially
within children
in china that was an issue so here's
this guy you see this guy on the screen
this this
i don't know what kind of face he's
making here and the pause was perfect
here this is what happens when you go
straight to no i'm just gonna
so so this this guy this guy
is gonna gaslight women in this country
about baby formula he's gonna gaslight
them
about about the oil pumps as if we're
not pumping [ __ ] oil joe biden
joe biden
has [ __ ] released more of our
national reserve to try to drop the
price of crude
um than than any other time in our
history really he keeps he keeps digging
into our reserve which i actually
disagree with i don't i actually think
that americans should bear the price of
gasoline right now um and they should
bear the price of inflation and the
reason why we see this cpi and they're
going to go on and on about [ __ ]
inflation and baby formula
because folks
they don't give a [ __ ] about americans
getting [ __ ] baby formula and this
[ __ ] here is gonna gaslight
women mothers about their children's
snap funds their children's wic formula
being stripped away from them because
republicans like this [ __ ] and his
father strip away from [ __ ] families
they're gonna gaslight the american
[ __ ] people are you kidding me
this is this is again folks they are
setting the ball up on the tee to knock
it out of the park in the midterms
they're doing this they think this is a
great message where they're going to
make democrats the the party who doesn't
want to feed children get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] you just go to
any vote any vote anywhere in any state
or the federal government that has to do
with snap or wick and get the vote count
of how many republicans voted the [ __ ]
against it that's all you have to do and
maybe that's what we start doing gabe is
we just start taking we find snap and
wick count votes and we just start
[ __ ] posting those [ __ ] yeah
and maybe we find some video of state
legislators and federal legislators on
in public record talking about how they
want to dismantle [ __ ] food
assistance in this country because they
[ __ ] they [ __ ] didn't even want
the farm bill which part of the farm
bill is food stamps they want to
decouple food assistance four children
away from the farm bill this gaslighting
lion [ __ ]
that they are four [ __ ] babies and
children getting fed that is a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] and don't let them
[ __ ] gaslight you or your neighbors
or your friends or your family family or
your community members you [ __ ] tell
them you tell them
the republic did you hear republicans
voted against food assistance don't say
food stamps because that's welfare food
assistance they voted against it
i'm telling you we have to get our
messaging straight on this because
that's what they're trying to do gabe
they're trying to make it where
democrats don't like babies you know
democrats are baby killers and they're
baby starvers that's what they're trying
to say
they're trying to build a message here
the other thing that people need to
realize is that the the baby
formula like supply
was already the the industry was already
shaky and rocky
uh what uh
november december january um and then
you had
these recalls that happened in february
obviously that's going to spike it up
and then you've got inflation
but the other thing that i didn't know
was that uh
there was before these because the it's
the chronobacter
uh setkazaki
chronobacter
sakazaki is it
not me yeah i know it's it's a [ __ ]
butcher it's a two eyes at the end
anyway chronobacter
sakazaki is a bacteria that causes a
rare but deadly infections in in babies
and that's what those two infants died
from then another four were hospitalized
that consume baby formula produced at an
abbot nutrition plant in
sturgis michigan the plant made a huge
chunk of the u.s formula supply now this
is the one i believe that don jr is
complaining about because people are
like oh no no we should reopen it we
should reopen it however what i did not
know that the same week that the plant
uh reported its first case
they were in the plant
in september 2021 so
it says the fda was in a in a plant in
september 2021 the very very weak the
first case was reported the eight to the
agency now the other thing the
is there was a whistleblower that had
warned top fda officials about food
safety concerns at the very at this very
plant in october 2021 months before the
two
two babies had died so what you have
here is you get a warning in october
they didn't interview the whistleblower
until december and they didn't expect a
plan until the end of january on january
31st and then the formula was recalled
on feb february 7th and the massive
recall including uh
similac which is the top brand of the us
and so now there's a big question here
which is like you've got to you've got
them who come in on september 21st or
september 21 2021 uh first case is
reported october 2021 you get a
whistleblower from the that very plant
who says hey look uh [ __ ] ain't good and
the formula needs to be looked into and
the fda needs to investigate and then
they don't do anything they don't they
don't do anything until december and
then january 31st they make this
announcement and then in the middle of
february they say okay we're doing a
recall
now
i don't know
what's going on in this like ladder of
people
but you get someone who reports on this
a whistleblower and then you don't act
for months later
like we shouldn't be talking about let's
reopen the plant right now because it
looks like we got some issue between the
fda and the actual plant in terms of how
the plant and the formula gets approved
that's the bigger question here so
you've got don jr
who's talking out of his ass about this
this this supply crisis which there is a
shortage right and we don't have a
national kind of backup supply to offer
and the other thing to remember too is
these issues that are happening right
now in terms of the supply they're not
they're not uh they're not they're not
um
they're not macro they're micro they're
only in certain areas right certain
areas you'll be able to find baby
falling no problem but other areas
you'll find it very very difficult the
the communities who are going to be most
impacted are lower income right the ones
that republicans don't really care about
the ones that they don't want to help
because they say oh that's a handout the
ones they voted against and snap right
exactly so they don't really care about
those they only care about the ones in
the upper middle class white privileged
communities where they only care about
the white babies not all babies the
white babies what happened to all lives
matter right it's all [ __ ] so you
look at this and you have to ask
yourself what's happening between the
fda
to actually act on this between a
whistleblower and two children dying and
four that are in the icu right uh
there's a lot going on here so you've
again you've got down jr who's trying to
force the reopening of this plant
that that caused this issue
and he has
just doesn't give any sort of context he
blames it on the democrats blames it on
biden when really you're like hey look
maybe we should take a step back and
really actually investigate we should
find out what's going on because we
already [ __ ] it up once
do you think don jr really gives two
shits about they know not at all doesn't
give two [ __ ] about baby for me the
other area
the other alternative is he's not really
talking about baby formula as the powder
or anything like that he's downright
different
different right right he knows about
powder that's right
white
formula
that goes in
maybe smoke it out of that
bong toy right whatever that is
background there right right you know um
[ __ ] [ __ ] don jr i will say this
so related to what's going on with the
fda so i don't know if anyone has
watched dope sick i just actually
finally got around to watching it
because what what's dope sick what
platform dope stick on dopestick is on
hulu i definitely recommend it it's got
michael keaton it's got a
a ton of other very very good actors and
actresses uh but it talks about the
opioid crisis and how purdue pharma
created
um oxycontin
and this what was supposed to be a
long-term release
um
opioid to help with pain relief right
and basically how
they worked with they had the fda in
their pocket to approve the drug and
make claims that it was non-addictive
and less than one percent this whole
thing i there's way more that has to go
with it with it but i definitely
recommend anyone who hasn't watched it
go watch dopesick it's a limited uh
series eight episodes very very good but
they do talk about this relationship
between purdue pharma and the fda
and how you know it's a little bit of a
you know money here and and you know
you mean specifically like the
regulators right right so the people who
are out there who are supposed to be
saying
uh yo
this is not safe you shouldn't have this
they say yo do they yeah they say you
know they say like in the official
meetings like that's another when
they're giving congressional testimony
they're like yo yo this
is not safe just making sure
but what i what i will say is i didn't
also know that rudy giuliani was
involved in this he actually was uh the
person that came up to litigate and help
support oxycontin and purdue to remove
any sort of um
personal criminal charges against the
family
so anyway the fda and and what's been
what's been going on right now that's a
big problem there is a big question mark
are there but also if you watch
something like dopesick it does make you
question
what incentives or what motivations
certain people have at the at the agency
that's supposed to make sure that the
things that you put into your body
are okay or your children's body like or
your children's body for sure
so and that's and that you know and that
is uh a good point because if
republicans have their way there
wouldn't be an fda if you've ever heard
of any [ __ ]
uh
republicans say anything about the cdc
fda any kind of fed well the only time
you quote the cdc is when they say that
the numbers right when it helps them
right and they're like well you can't
trust it and it's like where'd you get
that you know it's like oh i got it from
the cdc it's like so you're reading the
cdc you can't really understand what the
numbers and the data means
well speaking of data um i think that's
why katie porter is trending here gabe
yeah i'm reading here uh sarah ferris
says new uh she writes after rep katie
porter gives emotional speech to fellow
dems so i don't think we're going to
have a video of this because it sounds
like it was a caucus meeting um sarah
writes about skyrocketing she was
talking to fellow dems about
skyrocketing grocery bills katie porter
said it felt like the first time it sank
in with some colleagues and she's
talking about democrats specifically
here that the fact that skyrocketing
grocery bills would be a problem
not just for rural republicans but also
for democrats everywhere and american
people in general right um
one told her meaning katie porter it's
not coming up in polls
so sarah is reporting that someone it
doesn't say who here uh told katie
porter that it's not the the fact that
skyrocketing grocery bills is not coming
up in the polls
yeah her response katie porter's
response here was you don't know what to
ask also has anyone ever been asked to
to answer one of these polls because i
haven't right i haven't either i haven't
even i think polls are a bunch of
[ __ ] that's why we really don't talk
about him here i mean there was a i
listened to and now i i pay attention to
them and i listen to them to know what
the [ __ ] that they're spewing but i
don't i don't i don't
i don't agonize your you the listeners
to [ __ ] feed you full of a bunch of
stats and statistics and [ __ ] when
you know the truth you know the truth
about this stuff of course and i've said
it of course inflation hurts average
people it is a thing that [ __ ] with the
middle class it [ __ ] with working
people it [ __ ] with single moms it
[ __ ] with families the american people
are not having an easy time with
inflation and grocery bills
but here's the thing
here's the thing there are a lot of
different causes for this situation one
of the root causes in our immediate in
our immediate uh
current present that has happened with
grocery bills
is
uh we had the
the governor of texas stop and destroy
uh almost a half billion dollars worth
of groceries um at the border because
he's trying to create a crisis like gabe
was saying earlier and this is what they
do the other challenge that we're having
is the economy is really [ __ ] hot it
is a hot economy we see that the
unemployment rate is is still ticking in
the right direction we see that the cpi
the consumer um uh
production index
product index excuse me
is staying high
folks this is not a sign of a bad
economy it is a sign of an economy where
people are willing to spend money and
there is less supply more demand and
when we're talking about the economy and
we're talking about money and we're
talking about shared value in the
economy
that is the economy we want so here's
your options folks we can deal with
inflation in a really hot economy and
the reason why some of our inflation is
because we came out of a recession so
quickly because it really wasn't a an
economic recession it was a recession
brought on to us by the pandemic
so because we came in out of that
recession so quickly the economy is
heated so fast with a lot of the tariffs
a lot of the nonsense at the border
going on yeah
but here's your options we can deal with
inflation the way that we have to deal
with inflation or we can hope for a
recession
let me say that again let me say that
again we can deal with inflation the way
that we need to deal with inflation
or we can hope
for
a
recession now i'm not one that would
wish a recession on this country now
obviously the economy does what it's
going to do it is going to inflate it's
going to recess that is how economies
work especially in our capitalist
society
wait what wow that's how it works tony
that is how it works you're saying
you're saying there's a natural ebb and
flow there is a natural ebb and flow to
the economy and there is a lot of
outside republicans told me there's a
lot of outside factors there's not an
inflation button on the president's desk
now
here's the thing
you can either
put someone like katie porter
in charge
of your economy to fight inflation with
things like
extending the child tax credit and
inflation protection folks the democrats
gave american people and american
families money
in 2021 for inflation protection
via the the coronavirus bill that
congress passed and the president signed
the people who are stopping the
extension of the child tax credit the
inflation protection that democrats
built into our legislation is
republicans 50 of them say [ __ ]
you we aren't giving you the inflation
protection that you need and the reason
why
republicans know it's horrible horrible
for the democrats because democrats suck
at [ __ ] messaging
it's not horrible for the democrats
because the democrats know what to do
with inflation they know they know how
to handle inflation the fed right now is
trying to use interest rates to try to
beat back on inflation without causing a
recession this is this i i know
economics are difficult for republicans
to understand
and really honestly not every american
should have to run around every day
knowing the ins and outs of all the
economics how our markets work and why
it's affecting you but know this for
sure
know this for sure there is only one
party one party in this country that has
your interest at heart when we're
talking about inflation
and that is the point here that's what
katie porter is trying to point out to
the democrats that we need to get our
messaging straight on the skyrocketing
grocery bills and let the american
people know
why their grocery bills are high and
what the [ __ ] to do about it because the
republicans aren't going to offer any
solutions they're just going to say well
you can't give 40 billion dollars to go
fight putin what you got to do is
open up the baby for me a plant plant
even if it kills children like that's
their messaging that's their messaging
folks
that's what it makes me understand it
makes me think about something as you
were talking an analogy that could be
made about
why we might have inflation right now
obviously the
the
the situation is either we fall
ourselves we fall within a recession or
we have inflation right and that's
because we injected a lot of money very
quickly into the economy but that's
because people needed it now instead of
let's say that the economy is like um
you cook in a meal right you go to the
grocery store you get your ingredients
and you cook a meal in a pan
now
we
didn't give you the supplies at first
which is we didn't give you or rather we
didn't give you the time necessary to
create the meal for tonight's dinner and
that being trump denied anyone giving
any money right he was like oh here's
twelve hundred dollars here's sixteen
hundred dollars whatever it is like and
that should last two years that's good
enough right that's good enough to to to
pay your rent pay your mortgage raise
your family put food on the table all
you really need is like 1200 bucks right
meanwhile people don't have jobs and
they can't actually do it themselves
because you know companies go down
because they can't make money because
people aren't actually out in the
economy spending money as they should
now let's say you're cooking the meal
and you got the pan and you just want to
you just throw the [ __ ] on there you
just throw it on the pan you don't
really take the time to slowly heat it
up put the oil and make sure that you
know it's ready to go and that's what
happened we didn't take that time
necessary to actually prepare the meal
like we should have if we had invested
money slowly and enough money to
everyone in the country we wouldn't find
ourselves in a situation where you kind
of threw [ __ ] haphazardly into the pan
put the flame all the way high and now
you gotta scrape it because it's stuck
to the pan
that's where we are right now we're
dealing with the after effects of not
actually preparing the meal and cooking
it as it should have been we just kind
of threw [ __ ] in blasted on high and now
we're like oh [ __ ] it's burning and we
have to clean it up which means you have
to take the time after once you're done
with the meal to actually get the sponge
out scrub it down and put in a little
elbow grease that's where we are right
now and i look at that i'm like maybe
that you know you could say
whatever the analogy is but i look at
that as like you're trying to fix
something right away because you lacked
the preparation beforehand and now you
have to actually make up for it
so i i like your analogy that we have to
work hard as as pro-democracy people to
save our country not just not just on a
civics level but also on an economic
level um this this is important stuff
that that we get our messaging right all
around
it it is super super important that that
we know and we message that there's not
a [ __ ] inflation button on the
president's desk
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people we we have to and to give you an
idea gabe
the news is here house republicans is
trending um 57 republicans let me see if
i can bring it up here tuck tuck has it
here
57 republicans
republicans who stood with putin and
voted against 40 billion dollars in aid
to ukraine um now they're gonna talk
about all kinds of [ __ ] like inflation
and we can't spend this money because of
inflation and blah blah blah and on and
on and on
well putin is the aggressor
putin is the aggressor here that is the
important part that you have to remember
and it is not us who is doing this it's
not the democrats or the ukrainian
people
that are doing this
it is putin trying to tear down
democracy and folks if you want if you
want to not have to worry about
inflation if you want to have to not
worry about inflation
uh get you get you some putin style
tutorial ship here in the united states
and uh you won't worry about your head
about you'll have so much more to worry
about
than a little bit of uh gas braces going
yeah you probably won't even have to you
probably won't even know get gas gabe i
mean if you're if you if you're so lucky
you probably right won't get yes
again if you want to look at the
situation we have right now with
inflation you just got to look back and
look at the lack of or
lack of empathy the straight apathy that
republicans had to the american
situation during the pandemic remember
that these people who are in office we
put in we vote them in and they have the
ability to sit in their luxury kind of
lifestyle their full benefits six-figure
income
and
they're there to represent us
the fact that they
[ __ ] the bed right took advantage of the
situation
insider trading essentially on these
things within the pandemic left us
to kind of do our own thing didn't give
us the actual stimulus that the economy
needed because we couldn't actually go
out for the sake of public health like
you have to god damn they gave
corporations businesses and themselves
oh yeah and tons of money yeah oh well
you know you have to pay back this loan
you have to do this we're going to give
you money people took advantage of the
situation oh [ __ ] no duh that was
going to happen
but again these are the you wonder
what's going on right now why we have
inflation you have to look back at why
we are in the situation
we did not properly
prepare ourselves
for
this two year long
journey sprint if not longer that we
have to deal with
they just said 1200 1600 is totally fine
which i know helped people survive
but that is a very very small amount of
money i mean you look at like my rent
right now is
close to 2400 to live in los angeles
obviously that's not the same it's more
expensive in other areas down in florida
it's more expensive than san francisco
and new york
right but then that's only rent itself
that's not that's not including if i
want to ever get a meal if i want to buy
groceries if i want to pay for gas these
are all things that they just kind of
said yeah this is enough money this will
cover you for the time that you're there
right not including the fact that there
was a a backlog of unemployment the the
inability to get on the phone and
actually have a conversation with an
agent to get the benefits that we
actually invest back in because we pay
taxes
right
so you look at right now and you're like
yeah why do we have why do we have this
issue with our economy why are we having
inflation it's because
i mean i could go all the way back to
the beginning of the pandemic and just
the lack of empathy that and preparation
that we had from our own our own
lawmakers right
and the same type of app that you see
within 57 republicans who decided not to
fund this
this aid in ukraine same way it goes the
same way these are the same people
yeah we expect we expect them to have
the the courage for us like they don't
have the courage for the ukrainian
people like this is all [ __ ]
ridiculous that
we we expect them to post up for [ __ ]
putin but here they won't post up for
the republicans to take away wic to take
away snap why at the same time they're
bitching
bitching and bitching about baby formula
being off the shelves
because
babies were being killed by the formula
so they have to make sure that these and
if they're being killed
was reversed they would
in a
flip of a switch they would say we need
to put in trillions more we need to put
in we need to inject the economy with
cash we need to have this whole plan
when you have programs we have to do
this you know and of course obviously
it's only for the wealthy that they
would want to do well right i mean they
definitely want to make sure that the
wealthy get paid by their tax cuts [ __ ]
their constituents that's what they're
saying they don't care about them they
only want to make sure that you know
their safety their health and their
family
is okay but everyone else doesn't really
matter you know if you make it you make
it it is what it is right right well
that's the truth uh mj and ty thank you
very much for the uh
the super chat and the super sticker we
always appreciate um the support here um
and ty is a
journalist with occupied democrats also
a great person yes yes thank you ty uh
good friend of the show i i do i do want
to say here though uh speaking of
journalists um something as awful has
happened in the world today and i don't
care what side of the the the spectrum
you're on who you support who you don't
support
um a journalist was killed by israeli
soldiers it seems that is the reporting
um and i said i play the video i'm not
able to find this video back
that i want to play but i do have a
photo it is a graphic photo so i've
waited to the end of the show to show
this
but i believe that this
this is super important for the world to
see um for democracy because our press
as much as we may hate them as much as
they don't get the messaging right they
they both side [ __ ] sometimes uh the
press is vitally important to our
freedom and they need to do a better job
in this country and i actually showed
a clip from trevor noah
at the white house correspondents dinner
where he basically
gives
the press in that room the analogy that
hey
if if if the journalist in russia had
the ability and the speech that you do
and and the ability of the free press
would they be doing what you're doing
here
which is was a very very bold and
man it was a powerful um speech and it
was a powerful statement but here is a
picture now again
um we know that the journalist here i'm
going to take away the banner here the
journalist laying on the ground here um
do you ever do you have her name she's
with al jazeera i believe yeah uh
shireen abu ah clan okay
so shireen here um and her confidant
here you can see they have pressed flak
jackets on
um
now the video that i found earlier um is
of this scene and it's of uh bystanders
trying to reach the journalist that has
been shot here the reason why her her
colleague here is hiding behind what
seems to be a wall is because there is
someone still firing um if she peeks out
behind this tree in this wall here um
and in the video you can hear them
firing when she tries to look just to to
check on her colleague here who now we
know has passed away
um
this is this is super important people
that we know
that
journalists i and and i i really do not
give a [ __ ]
what their ideology is
um we have the freedom of press here in
this country and even if there is a
journalist who is a conservative or even
a fascist they have the right to to
actually write what they believe we have
the right to decide what they're saying
is the truth or not now they do not have
the right to endanger people i will
agree with that um but we need to be
very careful
when um we are demonizing the press i i
just want to you to know
that i believe in a free press um i
believe a free press is important to to
our democracy and our institutions
um to hold them to account now i i
believe that they're not doing the exact
proper job at least some of them are not
but this
this here
um is a stark image for our world and
the free world and western democracy in
general
that a member of the press who has a
press jacket on rather whether it was
the israelis or not that killed this
member of the press um this should send
shockwaves throughout the world and it
should piss off anyone
anyone
who is pro-democracy and it infuriates
me
um that this
this has happened and whoever is
should be held accountable should be
held accountable for what they've done
here um
this is disgusting i don't care what her
reporting is i don't care what her
ideology is i don't give a [ __ ] as long
as they truly are a journalist not
posing to be a journalist or trying to
spread their propaganda trying to be a
journalist
um this is a a strike to the free press
and to journalists around the world and
i just want everyone to know and the
journalists out there to know
that um i stand with democracy i stand
with the free press i stand um by your
right to be the free press even if i
disagree with you
uh on a political spectrum i still
believe that freedom and democracy is
the thing that will get us to a place
where equality and equity
is for all now it's not perfect you know
gabe i've talked about several times on
this on this on this broadcast
um that democracy is not perfect and
it's difficult democracy is really hard
and we choose to do the difficult thing
of democracy because autocracy is so
easy it's so easy to let one person
decide right
to make sure that the press does not
print bad stories about them to make
sure that the press does not tell the
truth about them because that would
expose them that would bring truth to
power
and folks these stark images that are
coming
um
of this
of this journalist being
what seems to be executed
um whether it's because she's the press
or not is very devastating
uh and it should it should it should put
a tear down your cheek
and that this is an assault on the free
press and democracy itself so
keep that in mind again i played this at
the end of the broadcast
because i i wanted to
it is kind of graphic i wasn't able to
find the video so i apologize but that
is a a steal from the video so
remember tomorrow thursday noon eastern
11 central we broadcast live here from
youtube twitter and twitch
and possibly as long as we're not
suppressed gabe maybe we won't go with a
putin um title tomorrow and see what
happens on facebook yeah i think i think
i think i think zuckerberg got really
mad that we
we uh
we were saying we were saying the 40
billion dollars wasn't for ukraine but
it was to defeat his
his almighty god putin
i don't know i think i think zuckerberg
is don't you think he's a putin cuck
don't you probably he probably i mean
he's like a you know robotic one but
yeah right
andrew android cuck
well speaking of cucks don't forget
tomorrow on thursday in the evening we
have the bone end of the week poll where
you vote on the bone of the week and
then friday in the second hour of the
show
we break down your vote for bone end of
the week so join us tomorrow and friday
noon eastern 11 century right here on
youtube twitter twitch and also
simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page until tomorrow folks until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking